so I've been doing some Japanese death
poems as I finish up my short film
dreadful misfortune I'll talk more about
that in the coming months but with
National Poetry Day coming up I'm doing
this collab with don't turn around where
we'll be reading some horror poetry I
thought it would be fun to practice
writing some Japanese death poems and
put a C ZZZ world twist on it so I'm
gonna base each of these poems on some
of my favorite horror anime and whoever
can guess what anime each poem is from
will win some kind of shout out or
something and stick around to the end
where I'll narrate the Japanese death
poem from my upcoming film dreadful
misfortune I opposed the move gazing on
empty caskets he inquired aloud aren't
you afraid of dying
I've been dead for some time now
[Music]
monsters roam this world but justice
will come swiftly as with all monsters I
know this monster because in truth I am
that monster the ninth grade class three
would be the last grade for me as with
those before a curse too great to ignore
ignore her to live one more
[Music]
12 contestants play a twisted and fatal
game when even peers lock even
friendship goes to shame she only has
her to blame the coffee's a bit strong
and this dates gone on too long city
lights so dim walked me home they look
so grim leaving half of me with him the
ink of this scribe is only seen in the
eyes of Shinigami who possess glowing
white eyes dreadful misfortune runs dry
the other voice you heard in this video
was don't turn around click the link
right here to listen to the epic horror
poem that I helped narrate on their
channel remember to subscribe with zzs
world for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive